[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهده
واياكم هذه الكلمه لرئيس الفرنسيه
بالنسبه للسلام في العالم نحن نعرف بان
هذه المجموعه هذه القمه ستكون قمه صعبه
ونحن نعرف بان هذه المناقشات ستكون مؤثره
بالمناخ العسكريه في اوكرانيا
صعوبه القصوى للاوضاع في الساعات الماضيه
وفي تحقيق الماضيه تحدثت مع
السلطات البولنديه قدمته تعازيه بشان
الضحك الذين سقطوا جراء صاروخين الذين
سقطوا على الاراضي البولنديه وعبرته لهم
عن
التزامنا بالوقوف الى جانبي
بولندا
حتى نكون في وضع
للناس يرفع في كل ملابسات هذا
القصفه وحتى نفهم ما حدث ونحن سنقوم بذلك
مع كل الحلفاء الذين اجتمعنا فيما بيننا
في صباح هذا اليوم وانا اتصلت مع الرئيس
المسك الذي
تحدث مرتين في اطار هذه القمه وعبرته عن
التضامن فرنسا اذا هذا القصر المكثف
صاروخيه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه همم بين
80 الى 100 صاروخ تم اطلاقها باتجاه هنا
تحتيه مدنيه
وفي اثناء هذا الاجتماع هذه الرساله كان
مقصوده من قبل همم روسيا
كما قلت ان هذا الخ الذي يقوم به لاستناء
الى
خياراتنا
وقراتنا نحن اردنا بان لا يكون هناك
انقسام في العالم
[موسيقى]
هذه القمه لا علاقه لها او لم تكن معنيه
بوقف الحرب ولكن كان علينا ان نرسل رساله
واضحه من اجل وقت التصعيد ومن اجل تحقيق
السلام ومن اجل عدم انقسام العالم وفي هذا
الاطار ورغم التوجهات المختلفه هذه
الرساله
هذه الرساله الواضح التي تم ارساله
للمجتمع الدولي وخصوصا الى روسيا حتى
النتائج المهمه من هذه القمه قمه مجموعه
العشرين حيث
هذه القمه وكان هناك فضاء
لتوافق الاراء بما في ذلك
الهند والصين من اجل دفع روسيا الى تخفي
الصعيد
نعم الرئيس بوتين لم يحضر ولكن الرساله
التي تم ارسالها من قبل قاده العالم
مستمعين هنا في بالي هذا الرساله كان واضح
معظم بلدان همم معظم بلدان الاغلب العظمى
من الاعضاء يدينون همم هذا همم هذه الحرب
بالاضافه الى القرار الاممي وهذه المجموعه
اعتمدت بما في ذلك الصين والهند همم بانه
وامامه همم التحديات فان هذه المجموعه لا
تريد الحرب ولا تريد الابتزازه انه بانه
امرنا غير مقبول وانا مجموعه ال20 هي فضاء
اقتصادي وكل هؤلاء يؤكدونا على احترامي
القانون الدولي وهذا ما ذكرته به عده مرات
انه احترام والاحترام الناجح للقانون
الدولي وهذا المحكمه
اوكرانيا في هامشي هذه
القمه
وغادات تحريري خيرسون وراينا بان الامور
بدات
تتا تغير
ولقد تبادلنا ايضا الحديث مع الرئيس
الصيني والذي عبر عن ارادته وعبر ضد اي
تصعيد النووي بصوره واضحه
للصين عن تطلع بدور للوساطه دور اكبر
اهميه في الاشهر القادمه
فقط
وانا تحدثت
بهذا الشان وايضا فيما يتعلقوا بزياره
المبدئيه الي بكين في بدايه
2023 وايضا تحدثت مع الرئيس الوزراء
الهندي
مع روسيا
وايضا الاكيد على تكثيف التعاون مع
الاعضاء الاخرين في مجموعه العشرين وهذا
هو الهدف الذي قام به في يوم الثلاثاء
مساء
همم عشيه هذه القمه الرئيسيه مع
السنغال والرئيس مجلسان وبصفته رئيسا
للاتحاد الافريقي ورواندا وجنوب افريقيا
والارجنتين والمكسيك
وذلك من اجل ايجاد تقارب في المواقف
وتوحيدها في المواقف حتى تكون هناك رساله
واضحه
ودعوه روسيا اللي وقفه حد لهذه الحرب
واحترامي القانون الدولي في هذا الاطار
كانت هذه القمه مفيده
ومن اجل توسيع التحالف من اجل السلام وهذا
العمل الدبلوماسيه الذي نعمله عليه الان
وفي السنه القادمه الهدف الثاني في قمه
مجموعه ال 20 نظري هو مجموعه يتعلقوا
بالامن الغذائيه كما اتعرفون وانا ذكرته
ذلك منذ شهر اذار مارس في الاطلسيه ان
الخطر الاساسي على الاجل القصير والطويل
الامر متعلق طيب
زعزعت سلسله القلم دادات الغذائيه نظرا
لهذه المنطقه المتعلقه بالحبوب
وايضا
على افهم فيما
فيما يتعلق ايضا بالموادي
المخصبه الزراعيه اذا مجموعه العشرين همم
استطاعت ان نوع من الاستقرار على القرارات
التي في هذا المجال
طبعا ان الممر الذي سمح به
ارسال كميات الصادرات من هذه المنطقه منذ
شهر نيسان ابريل وهم يمثل حوالي 60% وكان
هناك اتفاق برعايه الامم المتحده في هذا
الصيف وهذا الامر
باخراج حوالي 10 ملايين من الاطنان منذ
شهر ابسطس ولكن والنتيجه كامله بانه شهر
ابريل فان اسعار غذائيه قد انخفضت من جديد
ونحن نعمل من اجل ضمان التدفق اخراج هذه
الصادرات بسوره واضحه روسيا تهدد هذه
الاليه وهذا من شان نزيد من اسعار الحبوب
ان مجموعه العشرين في هذا المجال ارسلت
رساله واضحه الى الرئيس بوتين وكان هناك
عمل مهمه ومناقشات فنيه برعايه الامم
المتحده والممثله بالامين العام والاشكره
على ذلك اذا الاتفاق بشان الحبوب عبر
البحر الاسود
ينبغي تمديده بصوره ضروريه في هذا العام
هناك اليه ويمكن لهذا التمديد ان يكون
الضمينيا
وهذا يعني بان الاليات للمتفق بشانها من
ذئاب اغسطس من شانها ان تتواصل وايضا عبر
الطرقات المختلفه التي تم فتحها من اجل
استيراد وتصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه وايضا
تم ايضا
وفقا للاجتماع اللي جرى في نيويورك
في المنتدى باريس وذلك من اجل ايجاد ممر
همم
لتحويل الحبوب نقلها من اوروبا الى
افريقيا وهذا سيبدا اعتبارا من الاسبوع
القادم
وفلست ساهم بسته ملايين ونصف همم
ستكون هناك خطط طارئه ما اعتمادها في شهر
سبتمبر روسيا عبرت عن ارادتها من اجل اهي
رسوم جديده على
الحبوب
والمجموعه اذا كانت بانه من غير مسؤول ان
يتم فرض رسوم على المنتجات الزراعيه
التاكيد على
هذه الاليات ولا سينما في اطار مبادره
انيسه في المجال الزراعي وهذا يسمح لهم
وهذه الاليه تسمح بتبادل المعلومات في ما
يتعلقوا بالمنتجات الغذائيه
وبالتالي تم اعتماد هذه الاجراءات وفقا
لما اتفق همم اتفق بشانه
ورفع كل الحواجز امامه
الانتقال الحر فيما يتعلقوا بالحبوب وايضا
همم المخصبات اجتماع مع صندوق الدولي
والبنك الدولي من اجلي التقدم
امثل با النقل وتطوير القدرات الافريقيه
في مجال الانتاج ولا سيما فيما يتعلق
بالمخصبات
ضروريه للزراعه
هذا في ما يتعلق بشق الثاني من هذه القمه
همم هذا الشقه المتعلقه بالامن الغذائي
كما ذكرنا كانت هناك رسائل واضحه ونتائج
واضحه ولا اسيه اطفاء النوع من الاستقرار
على بعض الاليات المعتمده اصلا
سوجيفات مساج
الثالثه المهمه وهي ثلاث تضامن مع بلدان
الجنوب نعم قمه هذه القمه كان من شاني ان
تكون قمه للتضامن ان القمه الاندلسيه
والقمه الهنديه تؤكد على هذا الجانب
البلدان الفقيره ان تدفع اثمانا لازمات لم
يكونوا هم سببا فيها روما
وهذا يبين بين مجموعه 20 تفضي الى نتائج
ملموسه ان كنت تتذكرون منذ شهر مايو عام
2021 اطلقت فرنسا مبادره للخروج من
الجائحه من اجل مساعده الاقتصاديات
الافريقيه وذلك بعد التعاون مع صندوق
الدولي في شهر نوفمبر قبل ذلك ولا سيما
فيما يتعلق بحقوق السحب الخاصه بصندوق
النقد وليه بعد ذلك اطلقنا مبادره اخرى من
اجل اعاده تحويل وتخصيص حقوق السحب الخاصه
الى البلدان الاكثر احتياجا وهو ما يقابل
ما يقابل حوالي 100 مليار اا دولار ولا
سيما في القاره الافريقيه
في شهر
روما
الان وحتى هذه اللحظه تم تحويل همم
سته مليار خاصه الى هذه الغايه وهذا يبين
هذه القدرات ولا سيما بالنسبه لبلدان
فيما يتعلق اسعار الفائده واجال همم دفع
الاقساط بعد فتره معينه من الزمن قد تصل
الى 10 سنوات اذا نحن ذكرنا الاطراف
بواجبها اذا الان علينا ان ننتقل من 80
مليار الى مئه مليون اذن على الاطراف التي
لم
التزاماتها عليهم ان يقوم بذلك نحن نود
بطبيعه الحال ان نحسن الامور من الناحيه
من ناحيه التقنيه وبالتعاون مع صندوق
النقد الدولي وهنا اريد ان احيي هذا صندوق
في ما يتعلق بالابتكارات الماليه
وارددته وفي هذا الاوضاع التي اصبحت
متدهوره لبعض البلدان الفقيره والبلدان
داخل المتوسط
اتخذت الالتزمات مع بلدان اخرى من اجل
اعاده التخصيص 30% من حقوقنا السحب الخاصه
لهذه الغايه
بنفس الطريقه هذه المجموعه استطاعت ان
تتقدم فيما يتعلق باعاده هيكله الديون
البلدان الفقيره
وهذه الورشه الماليه في مجموعه العشرين
قمنا بوضع اطار مشترك للوصول الى هذه
الهيكله وصلنا الى همم
مع نادي باريس و البلدان الناشئه
السعوديه
وان يتم وضع اطار سنستمر على هذا الطريق
نذهب الى ابعد من ذلك
الجائحه والحرب في اوكرانيا وتداعياتها
وايضا تسارع تغير المناخ كل هذه الامور
تدفعون الى نذهب الى ذلك من اجله
تغييرا كبيرا همم نحو همم تغيير في مجال
التحويل الى الجنوب وان نستجيب الى هذه
الاحتياجات السريعه اذا في هذا الاطار
ونتيجه الى نتائج التي ذكرتها
والنقاشات التي اجريناها في هذه المجموعه
انا اعلنت في تنظيم مؤتمر
الذي ياخذ في السنه المضيئه في سنه
القادمه فيما يتعلق بحقوق السحب الخاصه
وان نتقدم ايضا في مساله عصرنا وتحديث
المؤسسات الماليه الدوليه اذا سيكون في
ايضا مجموعه السبعه التي ستعقد في اليابان
لهذا المؤتمر
في هذا العقد
مساعده البلدان الفقيره ونقوم بحشد وتعبئه
القطاع الخاص في مجال الطاقه والزراعه
وايضا من اجل تسهيل الوصول الى هذا الى
التمويلات وفي هذا العقد المالي الجديد
علينا ان نؤكد على جانب الهشاشه التي
يفردها تغير المناخ كما تعرفون ان تداعيات
تغير المناخ مهم جدا في هذه المناطق
وعلينا هنا الانجل ما حدث وما يحدث وما
حدث مثال في باكستان حيث بلدان متوسط
الداخليه هل يمكن ان تخضع لها
ضخمه قد تتعرض لها بعض البلدان علينا ان
ناخذ من الاعتبار هذه المعايير التالي منه
فيما يتعلق
بمساعده هذه البلدان ونحن قمنا بتقديم
تفويض لمجموعه من الحكماء
برئاسه رايت وزراء البرادوس ومن اجل
الظروف التي ينبغي بموجبها اطلاق هذه
الاليه
رئاسه
الامريكيه ايضا التي تطلع بدور مهم
وبالتنسيق مع اليابان التي تتراس مجموعه
السبعه
اذا رغم الحرب
وصلنا التقدم في مجال مكافحه التغيير
المناخ وتنوع الحيوي نحن علينا ونستطيع
هذه المجموعه واعمل هذه المجموعه
احد
الفحم في هذه القمه هذه المجموع اخذت
موقفا واضحا فيما يتعلق بالخروج من
استخدام من الفحم الحجري في مجال الطاقه
وهذا تم تاكيد عليه في قمه شرم الشيخ في
الكوب 27 وهناك انظر اخر فيما يتعلق
بالتوضيح في هذا المجال وبعد همم
وبعد الشراكه والاسيه مع جنوبي افريقيا
على هامش مجموعه ال20 تشارك في هذه
الشراكه من خلال تامين خاصه
كلاسيكو من اجل المساعدات البلدان
المختلفه
الفحم الحجري في مجال الطاقه قمنا بذلك مع
جنوب افريقيا الان مع اندونيسيا نستمر في
هذا العمل
نعم استطيع الحديث ايضا عن مجالس الصحه
وذلك في
استمرارا للجهود التي بدات
الجائحه ولاسيه ما تم تاكيد على عمليه
الوقايه والاستعداد
للازمات
في ايطاليا
مبلغ مقداره 50 مليون يورو لهذا الصندوق
وايضا فيما يتعلق ايضا بتحويل القدرات
للبلدان والبلدان همم نقل التكنولوجيا
والاسيه ما في ما يتعلقوا
باللقاءات المعتمده على تقنيه المرسال حمض
النوويه اذا مجموعه العشرين اكدت بصوره
واضحه على هذه الاستراتيجيه
اذا الاستراتيجيه في مجال الصحه
والتضامن
والوقايه كل هذه النقاط كما تعزيزها في
هذه المجموعه في هذه القمه واكدنا ايضا
على الجانب المالي واكدنا عن ارادتنا فيما
يتعلق
بانجاز
الرسوم الدوليه افضل رسوم الدوليه في هذا
المجال وهذه مبادره
طويله اذا في هذه القمه رغم مخاطر انقسام
فان همم روح السلام والعدد والعمل المتعدد
اطراف هو الذي
همم ان روسيا همم
بالاضافه الى المناقشات ما قبل القمه
اثناء القمه على مستوى المسؤولين على
روسيا الان ان تستمع الى الرساله التي
ارسلها مجتمع الدولي
المجتمعين هنا وان تعود روسيا الى طاوله
المفاوضات
هذه المجموعه بيننا نعجه في عالم
يعاد تركيبه من جديد وينبغي التاكيد على
فيما يتعلق بقواعد الحكم ولذلك نحن اردنا
ان تكون هناك اصلاحات بشان المؤسسات
الماليه في السنه القادمه ولذلك فان فرنسا
الاتحاد الافريقي في مجموعه العشرين وهذا
عنصر جديد من اعاده تشكيل وصياغه الهيكليه
العالميه اذا علينا ان نقبل بالاتحاد
الافريقي على غرار الاتحاد الاوروبي في
هذه المجموعه هذا اردته ان نقوله لكم
واريد هنا ايضا ان نهنئها الرئاسه
الاندونيسيه
والرئيسه
على وجه التحديد انه استطاع ان يرسل رساله
لوحده وان يحقق اوجه تقدم وبال
دي فهذه الاداب اصبحت اكثر وضوحا مما كان
عليه الحال في الماضي اسئلتكم الان
السيد الرئيس
طب يومكم فيما يتعلقوا بالصاروخين الذين
سقطاع على الاراضي البولنديه همم فهمنا
بانه ينبغي توخي الحذر وكانت هناك ايضا
بعد الشكر الامريكيه بشان ربما
اخطاء اوكرانيه
وتقول الان بانه هناك رساله موجهه من
المجموعه الى او رساله من روسيا الى
مجموعه العشرين فيما يتعلق ليس لدي
معلومات
حملها من قبل الرئيس الينسكي انا تحدثت مع
الرئيس اذا نسيتك
البارحه
اكثر من 85
على بنى تحتيه مدنيه
روسي
على الاراضي الهولنديه وانا عبرته عن
تضامنا مع الشعب البولندي
اليوم الظروف الحاليه لا تتيح لنا ان ان
نعزوا هذا
الصاروخين الى هذا البلد او ذلك صاروخان
سقطاع على الاراضي
البولنديه هناك اعمال اوليه
ساعات
الامريكيه وايضا اجهزتنا تعمل بالتعاون مع
الاجهزه البريطانيه والامريكيه وبالتعاون
الوثيقه مع الاجهزه الهولنديه لرفع كل
الملابسات وعندما يتضح ذلك فانه سيتعين
علينا
بصوره جماعيه ان نعبر عن ذلك في الوقت
المناسب وفي الاطار المناسب اذن علينا ان
نقول بانه 85
صاروخا روسيا ثم اطلاقه على اراضي
الاوكرانيه هناك صاروخان سقطاع على
الاراضي البولنديه علينا الان ان نقوم
برفع
لبسات وان نعبر الان عن عزائنا وتضامننا
مع الشعب البولنديه
وبكل تداعيات
الاستقرار التي تحملها هذه الحرب سؤال من
وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه
السيد الرئيس لقد تحدثت عن حمله القصف
المكثف الروسيه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
الى الامر كما اا لو انها كانت استفزادا
من روسيا
وبالتالي هل ما زلت تودع الاتصال
بتعتزم الاتصال بالرئيس بوتين
انا انظروا الى الوقائع
الى اعضاء مجموعه العشرين ولكن كل هذا لا
يغير من الواقع شيئا هناك ضحايا وهناك
ايضا دمار
طبعا رايكم موجوده الكرام هذه الكلمه
لرئيس الفرنسيه
بالي باندونيسيا والتي عاقبها هذا المؤتمر
الصحفي للرئيس ماكرون